[Music]
on this Tuesday night heartache in flood
ravage Nova Scotia the whole entire
province is
sick with mourning for the loss of three
Souls New Revelations about their final
moments plus the crews working around
the clock to search for the person still
missing
migrants stranded in the desert heat we
asked the crisis and brutal conditions
at the border of Libya and Tunisia the
eve of a major federal cabinet shake-up
in Canada who's out who's likely in and
why
plus Olympic organizers feeling the heat
it's just not safe the challenges of
climate change for next Summer's Paris
games
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
is another development in the search for
children who disappeared in flash floods
in Nova Scotia the RCMP say the body of
a second child was recovered this
morning the premier says Nova scotians
can handle a lot but nothing compares to
this
another incredibly sad day in a in
what's now been a series of terrible
days in this province
um the whole entire province is
sick with mourning for the loss of three
Souls now
we now know a bit more about how it
happened all four people were believed
to be fleeing their flooded homes when
their vehicles were caught in the surge
of water Mike Armstrong has our top
story from Nova Scotia tonight Mike
well Donna as the days have dragged on
it's gotten harder and harder to hope
for a happy ending here well today
police gave us some sad news
the bodies of the two children Swept
Away by flood waters and the storm this
weekend have been found one was
recovered Monday the other this morning
the body of a 52 year old man was also
found Monday but there is still one
person missing what police describe only
as a youth it's a tragedy that's
happened here is is really
it's really unimaginable really hard to
comprehend
Now new details are coming out about
what happened here Saturday morning at
about 4 a.m there were several people
traveling in two vehicles they knew the
storm was bad and we're trying to get to
a safer area that's when they were
struck with the storm surge as they were
leaving and we're kind of pushed off of
the road into a field uh that then
quickly flooded with water
now there were other people in the
vehicles who escaped they were rescued
taken to hospital and have been released
the search is a massive effort in
addition to police and firefighters
search and rescue teams from several
communities have been brought in there
are also volunteers local residents
strangers strangers they've been out
here for days hours
volunteering their time
and they care that mayor says some of
the Searchers have barely spoken to
their families in days they are instead
he says focused on helping other
families Donna oh
Armstrong in Newport Nova Scotia tonight
thank you
two Air Force pilots in Greece have died
after the Canadian made water bomber
they were in crashed while fighting
wildfires it was caught on video and a
warning it is disturbing you can see the
Canada airplane flying low dropping its
load of water its wing tip appears to
hit a tree and it crashes into a ravine
bursting into flames the pilots were
fighting a fire on the island of Evia
near Athens Greece has been plagued by
scorching temperatures for more than two
weeks fueling the wildfires at least 19
thousand people have fled the popular
vacation island of Rhodes and there are
evacuations in Corfu and the island of
Crete has now been put on high alert
Italy is also enduring wildfires and
extreme weather in the north torrential
rain violent hail and high winds downed
trees and damaged buildings at least
four people have been killed in the
South it is the extreme temperatures
causing chaos in Sicily where it hit 47
degrees Celsius in some places yesterday
wildfires are threatening towns and
cities and Resorts and tourist hot spots
are evacuating their guests complicating
matters the airport in Sicily's Capital
Palermo was temporarily shut down as
fires closed in it is now partially
reopened the extreme heat extends well
beyond southern Europe scorching
temperatures extend south to North
Africa and the Middle East the whole
region is caught in a prolonged stretch
of Relentless heat from Algeria to Syria
temperatures have soared well above 40
degrees this week with the thermometer
reaching 50 degrees in tunisia's capital
on Monday
that heat has been deadly in parts of
Northern Algeria where wildfires have
reduced entire villages to Ash officials
say at least 34 people have been killed
and more than 1500 have been forced to
flee about 8 000 firefighters are
battling the nearly 100 wildfires
burning in Algeria temperatures in the
high 40s are forecast to hold until the
end of the month
and in those blistering temperatures
dozens if not hundreds of migrants are
stranded at the Tunisian Libyan border
for weeks now they've been stuck in no
man's land with little or no shelter
food or water many had hoped to make it
to Europe but as Redmond Shannon reports
a new billion dollar deal between the EU
and Tunisia makes that dream next to
Impossible
parched and exhausted in the desert heat
wave begging for water
these videos provided by Libyan
authorities show what they say are
rescues of migrants from sub-Saharan
Africa
a child how old look at this for God's
sake document this for weeks both Libya
and Tunisia have effectively locked
large groups of people in no man's land
between the two countries there's no
food Syria we are sleeping so everything
is so dirty so strong we are suffering
we only have from Iran is what we need
please
here we have been drinking this river
water Libya says it found five people
dead in a remote border area Monday the
exact number of people still stock is
unclear earlier this month Tunisia
spelled hundreds of people to its Libyan
and Algerian borders after Rising
tensions and deadly violence between
migrants and tunisians
Tunisian president Kaya Saeed says his
country has treated all migrants
humanely but in February he blamed black
African migrants for crime and said they
were part of a criminal plan to change
the composition of the demographic
landscape of Tunisia since the expulsion
Tunisia signed a billion-dollar deal
with the European Union to control the
migration routes to Europe passing
through Tunisia similar to the deals the
EU has struck with Libya and turkey
handing over money to to the Tunisian
government despite the abuses being
perpetrated against these migrants and
Asylum Seekers is only going to
encourage those abuses to continue more
than 2 million people have paid
Smugglers to cross the Mediterranean to
Europe in the past decade hundreds died
near Greece last month while doing so
for these people that is a risk they
will gladly take to escape an open-air
prison in the baking heat Redmond
Shannon Global News London
in China a mystery is deepening within
the highest ranks of the government the
Chinese foreign minister who has not
been seen in public for nearly a month
is now out of a job Qin gong was removed
from office and replaced by his
predecessor authorities have given no
explanation or said where the
57-year-old has gone his disappearances
fueled lots of speculation including
rumors of a power struggle at the top or
an alleged Affair a career Diplomat he'd
served as the foreign minister for just
seven months a retired RCMP officer
who's been charged with foreign
interference has been granted bail and a
second former mountie has been linked to
the case it's alleged William Miker
helped the Chinese government identify
and intimidate a victim in Canada he
faces two charges conspiracy and
Preparatory acts for the benefit of a
foreign entity Miker had been living in
Hong Kong before his arrest in British
Columbia as part of his bail conditions
he must surrender his passport and
provide 250 thousand dollars in cash and
assurances
you heard was released on conditions
their conditions that were negotiated by
the defense and the crown because we
thought that they were able to address
the concern of concern of whatever
Flight Risk there is
Micah retired from the RCMP in 2007 the
offenses are alleged to have taken place
between 2014 and 2019. investigators say
they're not related to foreign
interference in elections another of
Mike's bail conditions he's not allowed
to communicate with another former
high-ranking RCMP officer Kenneth Kim
Marsh or FBI agent Ross Gaffney Marsh
was commander of an RCMP International
organized crime unit and has been named
an alleged co-conspirator in court
documents
prime minister Justin Trudeau is set to
make some big changes to his
government's front bench a cabinet
Shuffle is expected tomorrow at least
seven ministers are set to leave with
several other key figures preparing to
take on new portfolios Mackenzie gray
breaks down what we know
after weeks of Planning by Justin
Trudeau and his advisors the prime
minister is set to deliver his biggest
cabinet Shuffle ever I've made the
difficult decision to not run in the
next election transport Minister Omar
al-gabra one of four MPS including
procurement Minister Helena jazic and
Fisheries Minister Joyce Murray
announcing they won't run in the next
election
senior government Source telling global
news that true to inform ministers if
they weren't running again they'd be out
of cabinet I'm also stepping aside from
my role as Minister because the Prime
Minister deserves a cabinet who is
committed to running in the next federal
campaign but those aren't the only
removals Justice Minister David lametti
Public Safety Minister Marco Mendocino
and treasury board president Mona Forte
will also be dropped from cabinet
according to a senior government Source
I think this is an opportunity for reset
for reflection for the government you
know taking stock of who their best
performers are and making sure that
they've got the biggest challenges in
front of them with at least seven
cabinet ministers moving on that leaves
room for Trudeau to promote Fresh Faces
while also maintaining gender parity and
Regional balance watch for Mississauga's
Richie Valdez
ottawa's Jenna Suds Vancouver's Terry
Beach and Toronto MPS Yara Sachs and
Arif farani all to be sworn in as
ministers tomorrow at Rideau Hall I
suspect they'll be looking for a cabinet
that has the right energy to go the next
couple miles until the next election
there will also be a major Shuffle of
current cabinet ministers Anita onon
moves from defense over to an economic
portfolio Bill Blair taking her old job
at DND creating great middle-class jobs
while the changes are substantial many
of the top portfolios are set to stay
the same Christian Freeland continuing
on as Deputy Prime Minister and Finance
Minister same goes for foreign affairs
minister Melanie jolib and Industry
Minister Francois Philippe champagne
expected to lead the charge to try and
improve the Liberals declining whole
numbers quite clearly the the Liberals
are in danger if an election is
triggered tomorrow and let's keep in
mind that they are in a minority
situation and whether or not an election
is triggered is not necessarily up to
them the new cabinet will have roughly a
month to learn their portfolios before
the Prime Minister convenes a retreat of
his team in Charlottetown in late
Augustana whether to chart the course
ahead for the next sitting of Parliament
okay Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you
some Canadian researchers are calling
for an independent National inquiry into
Canada's response to the covid-19
pandemic in a series of papers published
in the British medical journal more than
a dozen Physicians and health Advocates
detail what they call Canada's major
pandemic failures they include
catastrophic deaths in Long-Term Care
Homes inconsistent Public Health
messaging and vaccine hoarding the
authors say an inquiry would be the next
step in the pandemic and an important
one in order to prepare for the next
emergency
forensic anthropologists have begun
excavation work in Manitoba as they
search for possible unmarked graves in
the basement of a Catholic Church really
looking for are there changes in the
soil is there anything to show us that
the soil is really mixed in and mixed up
because that's what tells us someone has
dug a hole and put something here
researchers will spend the next four
weeks combing through the basement of
Our Lady of Seven Sorrows church it's
about 400 kilometers Northwest of
Winnipeg last year ground penetrating
radar found 14 anomalies beneath the
church's dirt floor
Israel's doctors defend democracy coming
up their own fears about the country's
new judicial reforms
in Israel Mass protests on the streets
have now ended but the political crisis
in that country is growing today doctors
walked off the job and labor leaders
have threatened to strike over the
judicial reforms that weaken the
country's Supreme Court many fear it
will weaken democracy in Israel and as
Crystal gemancing Reports there are
worries other countries might follow
suit
black the color of mourning splashed
across the front page of four prominent
Israeli newspapers an ad apparently paid
for by a group of tech companies with a
line a black day for Israeli democracy
and wearing this black shirt today
because that's how we feel
government strip power from the Supreme
Court Banning it from striking down
policies for reasonability fearing how
the new law could impact them doctors
walked off the job Tuesday Morning the
minister has vast power and he can tell
the Physicians what to do in every
decision the Physicians cannot walk like
that the government turned to the courts
to Halt the 24-hour job action across
the country people are cleaning up from
Days of demonstrations with mixed
feelings I believe in the resistance I
believe in Israeli democracy I believe
in all the amazing people that were here
the past days
fighting
at times police and demonstrators
thought as roads and highways were
blocked in one incident a driver
attempted to plow through a crowd in
kafar Saba these dramatic scenes are
likely to reoccur Benjamin Netanyahu
made it clear more judicial reforms are
coming Democratic backsliding is the
term aerial Katz uses there can't be any
functioning democracy without or it's
interfering and reviewing and sometimes
voiding or declaring unconstitutional
actions of the other branches what's
happening in Israel he says goes beyond
healthy debate or correcting overreach
and that other leaders determined to
grab more control are watching when they
are successful that inspires others
right preventing in other countries
ultimately he says the changes will be
felt most acutely by minorities and
vulnerable people with Israel's
far-right government that means
Palestinians could suffer even more
nearly 7 million are repressed living
under Israeli military occupation in
Palestinian territories including the
West Bank
Crystal gemancing Global News London
Financial feasibility ahead Alberta
weighs the economics of hosting the 2030
Commonwealth Games
Alberta is considering a bid for the
2030 Commonwealth Games Australia just
dropped out of hosting the 2026 games
because of ballooning costs Sarah often
has more on Alberta's history with the
games and the risks involved of doing it
again
at 13 years old she was one of the
youngest athletes to compete in
Edmonton's 1978 Commonwealth Games a
moment that would launch Monica Gorman
into a lifetime career in sport to be in
a Canadian city an Edmonton home crowd I
mean it doesn't get any better than that
she won two medals at those games and
many more on the international stage
before creating her own gym I can say
that I play for a living because of the
direction that I've taken my work an
Alberta group is exploring reprising the
legacy of 78 with a bid for 2030.
bringing the Commonwealth Games back to
Canada where they first started it's a
really great opportunity for us to see
and show the world really where we've
come in all this time it's an
opportunity Australia's state of
Victoria recently opted out of
withdrawing from the 2026 games because
of ballooning costs and not without
precedent in 1974 an Edmonton task force
noted the original 1907 71 Commonwealth
proposal would cost 9.75 million dollars
it jumped to 44.6 million whoever's
organizing the event can come in and
dictate whatever they want they don't
like the grass replace it they don't
like the security setup change it they
don't like the barricades they don't
like anything they don't even like the
color of the seats change it so all of
those costs have to be borne by the host
City organizers say they're reducing
that burden by spreading the games
across Alberta and Calgary Edmonton and
First Nations communities we have a
strong volunteer base here and this will
be a really good Catalyst to help renew
that Premier Daniel Smith is asking her
minister of Tourism and Sport to develop
an international games bidding policy
requiring a referendum for affected
communities a decision on whether to
keep the bid moving is expected by
August goerman hopes it'll mean another
chance for young athletes to shine
competing on on home ground is one of
the most powerful experiences that I
ever was able able to experience zero
often Global News
next is a heatwave bake southern Europe
what's in store for the Olympics in
Paris next summer
[Music]
in just over a year from now the Olympic
Summer Games will begin in Paris and
today the Olympic torch for the 2024
games was unveiled it is Sleek silver
and symmetrical and it's meant to
represent the reflection of the Eiffel
Tower on the surface of the sane River
only 2 000 torches instead of about 12
000 from previous games will be made to
help reduce the game's carbon footprint
the organizers say they are focusing on
sustainability at these games though as
Eric Sorensen explains keeping athletes
cool in Europe sweltering summer heat
will be a challenge
Paris wants nothing less than a
magnificent Olympics to celebrate not
just competition but French culture and
history beach volleyball beside the
Eiffel Tower BMX in the shadow of
ancient sculptures and staging The
Opening Ceremonies on the scene the
historic River in the heart of Paris
this month a flotilla of boats did a
test run on the route we just believe
that all games needs to be different if
we want the people to to to remember
those games but one problem has only
grown since Paris was awarded the game
six years ago global warming
we now realize it's almost a certainty
we'll have high temperatures in the
summer of 2024 says the Paris organizing
director and we're organizing to ensure
the safety of athletes and others Paris
is cleaning the scene not just for
opening ceremonies but for some swimming
events many competitions from track and
field to equestrian take place under the
sun organizers suggest Olympic athletes
can perform in the heat the athletes are
used to compete every summer in extreme
conditions sometimes in in countries
they are able to to adapt but some
experts worry people coming from
different parts of the world one who are
not used to competing and participating
in this level of heat is going to be a
real problem on Tuesday the ioc
president Thomas Bach toured The
Athlete's village where special cooling
is being built into the floors to ensure
the athletes can at least keep cool
where they sleep this should be really
in order and to make the athletes feel
well and comfortable comfortable at
least until they step outside to compete
I think we're going to hear from some of
our health experts saying that this is
not an acceptable approach to hosting
any type of sporting event and we'll
have to rethink the model of the games
going forward because it's just not safe
extreme heat could see some competitions
rescheduled to early morning or
nighttime but organizers are committed
to staging much of the games at outdoor
venues Under the Sun and say they'll
just have to watch the temperature
forecasts as the games approach Eric
Sorensen Global News
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is Terra Nova National Park in
Newfoundland and Labrador we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
foreign